violeurs partout justice nulle part
c'est l'un des slogans
est-ce qu'on dès ce midi devant la cour
de cassation par les proches et soutien
de julie on rappelle les faits julie
c'est une jeune femme de 25 ans qui
accuse une vingtaine de pompiers de
paris de l'avoir violé entre 2008 et
2010 alors qu'elle est âgée de 13 à 15
ans au bout de dix ans d'instruction le
dernier magistrat en charge du dossier
décide de renvoyer devant la justice
trois pompiers sur la vingtaine mise en
cause tout en déqualifiant les faits
d'atteintes sexuelles il faut savoir que
le délit d'atteinte sexuelle et puis de
7 ans d'emprisonnement contre 20 pour
viol les proches et soutiens de la jeune
femme demande à la cour de cassation de
requalifier en viol les faits subis par
la jeune femme pour obtenir justement
justice pour julie on est là aujourd'hui
pour réclamer justice pour julie pour
être aussi auprès de sa maman pour que
nos riches qui se bat depuis dix ans
pour que
qui sont rendus pour sa fille ce que les
ventes ont pied pédocriminels qui sont
encore en poste mais d'en décharger soit
jugé pour viol
c'est un crime et non pour agression
sexuelle il faut que les faits sont
requalifiés conclat apprend de cassation
casse totalement largué la cour de
versailles où la boue j'ai aucune
confiance voilà elle justifiée je n'y
crois plus du tout à l'heure actuelle
alors aujourd'hui à quoi ces abus mois
on en france mais en 2021 et on peut
même pas croire en la justice
sept combats importants et qui montrent
défaillance de la loi actuelle pour
protéger les mineurs qui subissent des
violences sexistes et sexuelles
ça monte des vaillants de la loi
actuelle est d'autant plus important de
mener ce combat qu ensuite on voit bien
qu'il y aura des évolutions législatives
à faire porter au parlement français 4 %
des enfants victimes de viol je dépose
plainte
sur ces 4 % vous avez 75 % des plaintes
qu'ils aboutissent pas d'accord serre
qui sont qui sont classées sans suite et
vous avez seulement 0 3% qui finissent
aux assises 0 23% 2 4% ça veut dire
qu'en fait c'est l'impunité la plus
complète et fille qu'on peut penser en
france encore aujourd'hui temps en temps
peut être consentant à une relation avec
un adulte pour nous c'est un truc c'est
impossible on demande ardemment au
bissau au président de la république au
gouvernement de plus voir régulièrement
au sénat aux députés de pouvoir vraiment
posé de manière très claire et nette
dans la loi cet interdit qui veut
simplement dire un enfant je n'ai plus
jamais être consentant à une relation
sexuelle avec un adulte un appel
visiblement entendu par adrien taquet
qui vient de faire plusieurs
propositions pour mieux réprimer l
inceste et les violences sexuelles sur
mineures le secrétaire d'état elles
chargées de la protection de l'enfance
veut notamment introduire une
prescription est glissante un seuil
d'âge de 15 ans et une qualification
autonome d'inceste la cour de cassation
va t'elle requalifier en violent et les
faits subis par julie la plus haute
juridiction de l'ordre judiciaire
français devrait rendre sa décision dans
les prochaines semaines